well Nikki Haley's 2024 presidential
campaign is off to a very very Rocky
start on day one of her presidential
campaign videos from years ago were
resurfaced in which she defends the
state's right to secede from the United
States and also praises the Confederate
flag this is going to be a wild primary
and we knew that but this is what we
call candidate vetting the earlier you
announce the earlier you get vetted
apparently and this going bad very
quickly for Nikki Haley now remember
when we talk about the Republican
electorate they may not care about this
stuff so we'll talk about that in a
moment but let's go to the first video
Nikki Haley in 2010 was interviewed by a
group called the Sons of Confederate
Veterans quite a group about her
feelings about the Confederate flag in
this video she says the flag is not
racist and she would even support a
Confederate Memorial month you've got
black history month and Confederate
Memorial month why not right take a
listen to this
through and did the negotiations I
understand that it was brutal but I
think that they came up with the best
solution we're going to hope for you
know what people need to what I tend to
look at is the Practical side of the
matter is you know you had two-thirds it
takes two-thirds of the house and
two-thirds of the Senate to change that
that's not going to happen I think right
now the Confederate flag where it is is
where the legislature is comfortable
with it I think that you know there was
a compromise among the state
um where it should be and so it's not
something I see as a priority right now
I think right now we need to be focusing
on jobs and our economy and our
education you know for those groups that
come in and say they have issues with
the Confederate flag I will work to talk
to them about it I will work and talk to
them about the Heritage and how this is
not something that is racist this is
something that is a tradition that
people feel proud of yeah it's about the
tradition
of having slaves it's so funny when they
say the Civil War wasn't about slavery
it was about states rights and there
should be an ellipsis there states
rights to maintain legal slavery it's
about the tradition that included
fighting to keep slavery legal and let
them know that we want their business in
the state and that the flag where it is
was a compromise of all people that
everybody should accept as far as South
Carolina
produce for the Confederate History
Month in the study
and so when you look
you look you have as soon as you have
black history month and you have
Confederate History Month I I
satirically said that that's very at the
start of the segment I satirically said
listen why not Confederate History Month
you've got Black History Month why not
Confederate History Month of course that
ignores the reality of what the
Confederacy was I I I'm actually stunned
I jokingly made that analogy and she's
seriously making the analogy all of
those as long as it's done where it is
in a positive way right not in a
negative way the positive aspects of the
Confederacy like for example they did
feed their slaves after all it doesn't
go to harm anyone and it goes back to
where it focuses on the traditions of
yes
um the people that are wanting to
celebrate it and I think it's fun
yeah Confederate History Month there is
an idea uh here's a bonus clip from this
same interview with the Sons of
Confederate Veterans
she uh played up the right of states to
secede
um let's take a listen to this this is
not a good could this be the worst first
day of any campaign uh for president do
you believe that the states of the
United States have the right Community I
think that they do I mean the
Constitution says that the constitution
does not say that
if it became
an issue where the South state of South
Carolina needed to secede from the union
will you support it you know I'm one of
those people that doesn't think it's
going to get to that point
while we are seeing all of this Federal
intrusion come into our states the way I
will handle it is I'm going to get a
coalition of Governors to go if it turns
around let's take the health care
situation for example I'm going to get a
coalition of Governors that turns around
all right so now she's doing her
political nonsense so states don't have
a right to secede it this is a subject
of much legal controversy Texas V white
from 1869 is one case that's pointed to
where the Supreme Court ruled that
unilateral secession isn't
constitutional meaning
if a state Alone says we want to secede
and become our own country that is not
in the Constitution that you can do that
there is the idea that either uh but
there's the idea that through the
consent of states it could be agreed
that some state would leave the United
States but Nikki Haley saying listen
states can do it states can secede uh it
all also it's not accurate as much as it
is cow Towing to uh what a really pretty
horrible groups in this case sons of the
con of Confederate Veterans so this is
going to be a very tough primary and
it's going to be tough not just because
uh it is uh Trump is a formidable
Challenger not in terms of policy but in
terms of rhetoric with the nicknames and
the attacks Etc there is one aspect of
Challengers to Trump that is good for
Trump and it is the following
and this is why there were some rumors
that he wanted Nikki Haley to get in and
many people said sir why why why when
you look at head-to-head polling Trump
versus DeSantis in many head-to-head
polls DeSantis actually is ahead of
trump in 2024 polling when you do
polling that includes Mike Pence and
Nikki Haley and Mike Pompeo and whoever
else the more candidates there are in
the hypothetical 2024 polls the uh worse
that Ron DeSantis does and the better
that Trump does in comparison so that
would be a reason for Trump to want a
crowded field that being said I am not
particularly bullish if I were a betting
man
I don't know that I'm betting on Nikki
Haley to be the next Republican nominee
so there it is
um quite quite a wild first day for
Nikki Haley if this is day one imagine
what week one is going to bring a
Republican Senate minority leader Mitch
McConnell is scared he's scared to
disavow Donald Trump and to say it's
time for the Republican party to go in a
different direction we know it's what he
thinks Mitch McConnell made it very
clear in that speech he gave on the
floor of the Senate just days after the
January 6 2021 Trump riots we know uh
that Mitch McConnell is not pleased with
Trump he is not pleased with Trump
politically he's not pleased with Trump
ideologically I can't imagine that he
sees Trump positively after Trump has
made numerous racist comments and dog
whistles about Mitch McConnell's own
wife Elaine Chao based on her Asian
Heritage there's no way in hell for all
of the bad things we can say about Mitch
McConnell there's no way in hell Mitch
McConnell is a trump guy but Mitch
McConnell also uh in many cases puts
politics above his individual beliefs
and above principle and so Mitch
McConnell isn't willing to say
I don't want Trump to be the next
nominee and I don't want Trump to be the
next president Mitch McConnell is saying
I will vote for whoever ultimately is
the nominee and in fact yesterday he was
asked by CNN's Manu Raju on the heels of
Nikki Haley announcing that she too is
running for the Republican Presidential
nomination he was asked will you support
Nikki Haley and he sort of said well
it's going to be very competitive and
then he said he will support whoever is
ultimately the nominee
you might have Nikki Haley's decision to
jump in to the race today do you think
that it's time for the party to find you
fresh face and move away from Donald
Trump well what I think we're going to
have is a vigorous primary vigorous with
the number of candidates making their
occasion
and the American people those who are
registered Republicans who are going to
participate in these primaries are going
to decide who they want to nominate and
I think it's going to be very very
competitive in these primaries and we'll
hope for the best and obviously I'm
going to support whoever the nominee
ultimately is obviously obviously there
is no scenario in which Mitch McConnell
would not support whoever is the
eventual nominee now there are people
who will write to me and say David that
it's really not a big deal that Mitch
McConnell is saying that he's a
republican he's in Republican leadership
of course he's going to support whoever
the candidate ultimately is we know that
no I get that the problem is that it's a
Brazen partisanship where for the good
of the country I would like to see Mitch
McConnell at least be open to the idea
that if the nominee were truly horrible
he would think for himself and even
though I know he would never say it it
would be nice to hear from Mitch
McConnell something along the lines of
listen I am a Republican and I have
faith that Republicans will select the
best candidate to represent us but I am
not but a blind follower and I am not a
moral and while I disagree with Joe
Biden
he is a good man and an honest man who
wants what he believes is best for the
country and if indeed the Republican
Party selected someone that I believe
would be destructive to this country I
would cross party lines he'll he never
can do it it's of course never going to
do it he will always end up justifying
the vote for the Republican but I would
like to see them at least pretend not to
be overtly partisan hacks
they would be lying in a sense so am I
saying I would like to see them live
well though I would love for that to be
the truth it is not and so Mitch
McConnell is being honest yeah Trump
said racist things about my wife yeah
Trump incited an Insurrection yeah I've
said Trump is a problem in so many
different ways but I'm going to vote for
whoever is the nominee even if that is
Donald Trump and this is similar to the
bill Barr line we when we saw these
recent interviews by uh Bill William
Barr
Trump's former Attorney General
criticized Trump significantly and then
say well I'm not going to vote for a
Democrat obviously not going to vote for
a Democrat they are telling the truth in
that sense and uh at least for once they
aren't lying but Mitch McConnell making
it very clear whoever they put up there
he would vote for over a Democrat we'll
have these clips available for you on
our YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show we also have the
YouTube channel in Spanish now available
closing in on our first thousand
subscribers on the Spanish YouTube
channel which you can find at YouTube
actually you know what I'm going to set
up a redirect
davidpackman.com Spanish okay just to
make it easier
davidpackman.com Spanish will take you
to the Spanish language YouTube channel
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
remember that your support at
joinpakman.com is primarily what funds
this program it funds the podcast and
the YouTube channel the dubbing for the
Spanish YouTube channel team salaries
and health insurance all of these
different things are funded primarily by
people who go to joinpakman.com and get
themselves a membership we also provide
really great perks to our members
including an extra show every single day
called the bonus show oh the bonus show
are you want to make money yeah
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves as bad I can think of No
Greater endorsement of the bonus show
than the fact that Alex Jones hates the
bonus show we also make commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
available hours earlier than we publish
the show to everybody else we will have
continued members only Town Hall events
and we also have a member-only sound
board where you get access to my
soundboard like the one I have here
Obama yeah Obama is on there yes you can
go to joinpakman.com get yourself that
membership quick and easy right Wingers
are completely losing their minds over
this train derailment that took place in
Ohio now one of the reasons I've not
said much about it yet is that it is
still really not clear what or who is to
blame and the right is very quick to
blame woke and racism for the event that
took place which is a really strange
thing to do and to blame it's
conceivable that what we have here is a
problem in terms of lack of Regulation
it it's really not clear yet the NTSB
report so far
says that the um uh and the the cause
here was a malfunction with a wheel
bearing which overheated and it's not
yet clear what caused the wheel bearing
to overheat now of course there are
concerns about chemicals in the area
both in the air and the impact on water
quality Mike dewine said he would be he
would stick with the bottled water for
the time being Aaron Brockovich is
expressing concern about whether there
are more harmful chemicals than what is
being revealed we we are still trying to
learn a lot about it but many on the
right have figured out what this is all
about here's Greg Gutfeld he believes
wokism is to blame mayor Pete is busy
he's got some pretty big issues that
he's dealing with for example did you
see what he said about construction
workers that it's really a problem that
their skin color doesn't match the
diversity of a community and that's
really got to upset people I remember as
a kid walking around and I was very
upset whenever I saw of mine I like a
minority construction worker I was like
my God now understand that these are two
completely separate issues and if indeed
mayor Pete weighed in about diversity of
construction workers it has nothing to
do whatsoever with this incident but Fox
News doesn't care about that they all
have to look like me you know I had that
was a secondary that was a primary
concern the the all the other things
about safety and whether the product was
so that was just that was not as
important this is the problem with
catering to the woke they don't have
time for real problems so they chase
these completely made up ones train
derails or a plane crashes but they
worry about the white construction
worker offending somebody who doesn't
exist I don't believe a single person
has ever expressed a problem about a
construction worker's skin color unless
it was another skincare another
construction worker but this is the if
you want to talk about a a toxic spill
look at what look at wokism and what
what what politics is doing to every
part of life I mean okay so Greg Gutfeld
says wokism and Pete bootage being
distracted by wokism is the problem
Charlie Kirk goes even further and his
do I even call it an analysis Charlie
Kirk says the Ohio train derailment is
part of the war on white people and
remember oh the left is always victim
they're they're the victims
it is the right that is now regularly
saying Christians are the victims and
white people they're the victims and
conservatives are the victims here's
Charlie Kirk's analysis of the situation
not a single member of the Biden regime
would dare to go
to this portion of Ohio and breathe in
the air because they know it's dangerous
they know that it is actively poisoning
the citizens
of Eastern Ohio so why is it that they
kind of shrug their shoulders
and they say ah yeah okay whatever it's
very simple it's because the war on
white people continues right
why would you care for the white
working-class voters in eastern Ohio you
haven't cared about them in other
reasons or other portions and I will
prove it to you
if this train derailment happened in
downtown Atlanta in the densely
populated black neighborhoods
this would be the number one news story
it would be Flint Water Crisis 2.0 the
speed oh well that's interesting we know
how sincere Charlie Kirk is in saying he
would be just as concerned obviously if
the train derailment disproportionately
affected black people because of the
years that Charlie Kirk has spent
talking about the Flint Water Crisis oh
wait he hasn't spent years talking about
the Flint Water Crisis and so this is
yet again we are the victims it is
racist or it's Reverse Racism which is a
delightful term that they like to talk
about but what they won't discuss is
whether the train derailment might be
the result of corporate greed and
deregulation now I'm not ready to say it
is understand I want to follow the facts
and based on the NTSB report so far it
isn't clear to me that the issue here is
one of corporate greed and deregulation
but if we're speculating about what this
is and we're going to speculate well
it's because of woke or it's because of
anti-white racism or whatever the case
may be if we're speculating let's
include more reasonable speculation as
well then we go to Marjorie Taylor green
Marjorie Taylor green says the issue
here is Pete Buddha judge that's really
the problem that's the cause but the
real problem Sean is Pete buttige he's
the Secretary of Transportation and he's
more interested in equity and inclusion
in his hiring practices and Grant giving
schemes and and obviously probably chest
fading or something like that then he is
rail safety now chest feeding this is
something that Lauren bobert started
with Pete butterjudge it's just straight
up homophobic Buddha judge took
paternity leave
that's the story and they talk about
maybe he was home chest feeding and of
course this is what they are saying
because Pete Buda judge is gay that this
this is a homophobic attack on Pete
Buddha judge If This Were you know I
don't know uh
I don't know I I was going to say George
Santos but Santos is gay I the point
here is they're talking about Pete
bootage's chest feeding because of the
stereotypes about gay men being feminine
so the homophobia continues but more
importantly here Marjorie Taylor green
is saying oh there's a Democrat who is
Secretary of Transportation let's blame
him for what took place in Ohio rather
than all of the Ohio infrastructure and
political uh establishment which is
overwhelmingly run by Republicans no no
no it's the fault of Buddha judge in
Washington DC and that's where we have
real danger in our country yeah you see
Pete Budaj was never qualified for the
job and sort of like she's not qualified
for her job I believe we need to haul
him in in our committees and start
questioning him over what's actually
happening in his Department because
train derailment is happening every
single day and now thousands of people
uh Birds animals they're all sick and we
don't know the consequences of this
horrible accident in East Palestine yeah
you know she throws in train derailments
are happening every single day that's
one of those statements that's true and
is completely misleading
when you look at what that means there's
about a thousand incidents a year that
are called train derailment incidents so
it is like three a day understand that
the overwhelming majority of these are
minor incidents with absolutely no
injuries never mind deaths often
involving a city uh rail Transit like
Subways and commuter rails and this sort
of thing often they're weather related
their derailments of you know a part of
one car uh and it's really not
representative of any kind of
particularly major problem and of course
it happens whether the Secretary of
Transportation is a democrat or a
republican under Elaine Chao as
Secretary of Transportation you also had
about a thousand derailments of
different kinds of years so it's all
dishonest it's all nonsense but they
don't care they just want to find
someone to blame
um one more clip here real quick this is
Jesse Waters saying this is the the
racist black EPA administrator trying to
hurt white people so where's the EPA
if they say my plastic straw is
destroying this country
then they must be all over a
cancer-causing gas bomb in the Ohio
River Valley right
or the random toxic Ash that's raining
down in Illinois
by the way it's funny how now suddenly
conservatives care about pollution in
the environment actually the EPA
administrator Michael Reagan no relation
to Ron is too zoned in on electric
school buses to care about poison
drinking water he just announced
pledge to support electric school buses
Nationwide
you have cancer here's an electric bus
does this guy Reagan even know anything
about the environment well we looked
into him and the only reason he was
nominated to run the EPA was because he
promised to fight off environmental
racism
is this his idea of fighting
environmental racism spilling toxic
chemicals on poor white people in Ohio
why do you make everything about race
they say to the left why why do you see
race in every issue well it seems like
these right Wingers are very much seeing
race in this issue unhinged brain worms
is what they're suffering from but
people hear it and they fall for it
Carrie Lake was confronted by Piers
Morgan in the interview I've been
waiting for for a long time you know I
I'm not a particularly big fan of Piers
Morgan and in fact his producers have
been extraordinarily unprofessional in
their dealings with me and and just
their lack of organization and
discussions we've had about me appearing
with them but this is just fantastic I I
hold no grudge and I I blame him not at
all for that he does a fantastic job
here in confronting failed Arizona
Republican gubernatorial candidate Kerry
Lake and he's straight up says her
there's no evidence that you really won
she she insists I won
she insists there were irregularities my
opponent cheated we've got lawsuits all
this different stuff take a look at this
and look at how flustered she gets
really nicely done by peers there's been
no independent corroboration that there
was anything fraudulent about this
election in fact it's pretty clear that
you lost 2kt Hobbs your your rival 50.3
to 49.6 and as with Donald Trump but I
said to
lots of rabbit holes
there's there's a mountain of Hard
Evidence and when we presented it in our
trial the other side didn't even dispute
the evidence now that's such a lie it
it's it's so deceptive when she says
that the other side didn't dispute the
evidence she says they didn't need to
because the so-called evidence was
nothing it was so faulty and bogus that
a judge said I don't even have anything
here to potentially move forward on
remember that they made 10 complaints to
a court
eight of the ten complaints they simply
had no grounds for whatsoever the other
two complaints the judge heard and said
okay what do you have and the judge said
there's nothing here it's like if I go
into court and I say bananas are
actually electric vehicles and the judge
says that's nonsense we can't move
forward with that and then I go the
other side never disputed it I said that
bananas are elected they never well no
it's the judge said it's so absurd we're
not even moving forward and Carrie likes
well but they didn't dispute it she is
such a liar
the election results
yes well we can't continue to run
elections this way and we know that we
won and we're going to continue to fight
this in a court of law and it's really
rich that you're sitting across the pond
acting like you know what you can't
possibly know whether I won peers if
you're in London happened on Election
Day I did not see your smiling face we
had lots of international media here
covering elections it would have made no
difference her opponent got more votes
today in Arizona yours is one face I
didn't see in nor did I see it you could
have had my smiling face but arizonans
I would have loved to have seen you we
had more media covering our election
than I've ever seen cover any any story
here wow and despite the record media
coverage they still got away with
cheating that's stunning Carrie Zona and
as I said I covered Arizona for nearly
30 years so it's okay that you are not
comfortable with me fighting this
election and fighting for election
Integrity
I don't I don't mind your fighting
spirit I don't mind in Donald Trump I've
known him a long time well I have every
right to fight this election no one's
arguing it isn't her right it's just
baseless and she's grifting but it does
come on point if you're doing this
it does come a point when for the future
of democracy you and Donald Trump have
to accept at some point you lost an
election otherwise the entire system
collapses if your simple response to
losing is always we didn't lose we won
then democracy science
Pierce I grew up in a family of nine I'm
the youngest my father oh well that
changes everything then there was a
history and government teacher and a
football coach and he taught us that if
we lose and we lose fair and square we
we congratulate the winner we walk away
and that's exactly what I would do if
that was a fair and square election but
I'm fighting for the people of Arizona I
go I mean guys are dad coached football
obviously she wouldn't lie over this
country I've been probably to Six States
since the election in Arizona I can't
walk 10 feet without an arizonan saying
I voted for you everybody I know voted
for you our ballot was rejected on
Election Day please keep fighting for us
I'm fighting for the people of Arizona
every 10 feet people are saying it was
stolen that's stunning stuff huh and I I
don't mean any offense to you but I
frankly don't give a damn what you think
about it
I totally am no offense taken whatsoever
let me ask you this Pierce let me ask
let me ask you a question do you think
it's right that you show up on Election
Day that's the big day on Election Day
and 60 percent of the voting locations
in the primarily Republican locations
have ballots that are printed out wrong
machines
albeit from mine is that okay all I know
from my lofty uh place here in London
and I admit I wasn't in Arizona it's too
far to know what happened guys London's
very there's water in between that is
all the official fact-checking entities
that have looked into all the claims do
not conclude
come on
Pierce Pierce did you just fall off the
turnip truck we know about the fact
Checkers and we've seen them this has
all been guys despite record media
coverage of the race the media didn't
notice the cheating by Katie Hobbs
because the media is complicit and the
fact Checkers didn't notice the cheating
by Haiti Katie Hobbs because the fact
Checkers are just left-wing loons and
the courts didn't recognize Carrie
Lake's evidence because the judges are
left-wing loons even though many of them
are Republicans revealed half of them
are leftists working for face there it
is let's be real okay
one final Point what did they know
they know at what point would you accept
that you've lost never
well do you think that we have a right
to move this through the court system he
already said it's not a question of
whether you have a right Carrie I think
we do I know that we do we have the
rights
anyway you see the the direction this is
going she sort of has to do this because
at a certain point if she just goes hey
you know what
I was wrong I just lost
she can never run again and she's
thinking about running for Senate and
she wants to have a political career so
really really nice job there by Piers
Morgan Carey lake is a liar and a
grifter and I know she doesn't really
think she won she knows she lost but she
has to do this
if you value what we do at the
show remember to support us on patreon
go to patreon.com davidpackman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos The Daily bonus show the
commercial free Daily Show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today we
welcome to the program Matthew Connolly
who's a Columbia history professor and
also author of the book the
declassification engine what history
reveals about America's Top Secrets a
really great having you on today I
appreciate your time great to be with
you David so you know we've been talking
about these recent classified documents
I guess it's it's fine to call them
scandals or news stories involving
Donald Trump and several hundred
documents and then Joe Biden and Mike
Pence reportedly with a small number of
documents that they didn't appear to be
deliberately keeping at their homes or
offices which is certainly a difference
to what we know so far about the Trump
story but there's sort of like a zooming
out that we can do more generally to
think about what sort of documents are
classified are we classifying the right
number of documents are there things
that are over classified and actually
reducing transparency so maybe to start
with what is the history of this concept
of these sorts of classifications that
that have been created
yeah well you might think you know that
this is something that governments do
you know you could think of it like
death and taxes right that uh government
officials would like to operate under
the cloak of secrecy but the fact is the
United States uh compared to other
countries anyway was really an outlier
you know for the first 150 years the U.S
was quite remarkable you know I think a
lot of people probably know we've never
had a Central Intelligence Agency uh we
we also unlike other countries we didn't
have what they used to call Black
Chambers where they would intercept and
decode Communications I mean almost
every other country the size of the U.S
uh had you know the means and actually
the motivation to track subversives they
would intercept their mail and so on in
the United States that was a felony so
you know both on the one hand it was a
matter of the US government not really
creating a lot of Secrets and then on
the other hand people had a very high
expectation as to their own personal
privacy so what we now take for granted
you know what some people call the
national secrecy complex you know what I
call the dark State it's really an
invention that lasts 80 years or so it
really only started after the second
World War
and when we talk about what types of
things are classified secret top secret
Etc all these different designations I
think the assumption is always that
these are extremely sensitive pieces of
information often related to probably
more foreign policy than domestic policy
I think that the assumption but there's
relatively mundane things that are also
designated in these ways oh sure you
know uh so it's interesting there's a
kind of you know dual dialogue going on
about secrecy where you know when you
bring out people who have their security
clearances and spent years in the
intelligence Community or what have you
yeah they'll tell you about all these
rules and how elaborate they are and how
careful people you know have to be but
the reality is you know if you actually
study this history and you look at what
people do every day they'll tell you
yeah you know I had to meet a colleague
for coffee and I classified that email
as top secret because because you know
at some point in the long email chain by
the time we finally figure out you know
which Starbucks you're going to I may
have said something about some program
you know that could be classified so
better safe than sorry you know and and
this is how you end up with what is now
a completely unmanageable situation you
know the state department generated some
2 billion email a year so just think of
the volume you know of these coffee you
know emails that end up being top secret
where for decades nobody's ever going to
see them unless somebody reviews that
stuff Page by Page to decide the rest of
us are allowed to read it so it seems
that the sort of most obvious concern
one would have about over classification
would be it reduces transparency there
are documents here that you know maybe
we don't post everything but at least
through foia requests should be
available if someone wanted them and you
reduce transparency if you over classify
is it that simple or what other concerns
are there with over classification
well you know for me as a historian I
care a lot you know about what a lot of
other people too would say is the court
of History you know because you know if
and it's true we have 18 different
intelligence agencies we have an 800
billion dollar defense department we
have this vast apparatus that's carrying
out covert operations you know targeted
assassinations you know wouldn't you
like to think that at some point you
know someone is going to be able to look
at all the evidence right to even if
it's only the court of History to hold
our leaders to account you know but I
could tell you that's just not going to
happen you know because even before the
era of electronic records you know this
age of Big Data the National Archives
could only keep about one to three
percent of the original documentary
record and if it's the case and it's
true we now have just to take another
example we have one intelligence agency
that's producing a petabyte of
classified data every single year if
those were paper records and they were
are lined up in file cabinets and file
folders it would Circle the equator and
even the government says it would take 2
million archivists just to go through
that to decide what the rest of us are
allowed to know so yeah that's important
I think it matters because if you think
you know history matters and ultimately
you know holding our leaders to account
that matters quite a lot but I'll tell
you the other reason it matters and this
is also not trivial when they can't
decide what's actually secret they can't
protect the stuff that really could kill
people and we've just seen one after
another you know and these really are
scandals like NSA CIA hacking tools you
know getting stolen we've seen you know
the Chinese government apparently taking
tens of millions of personnel records
with which they could use to Blackmail
people who do have top secret security
clearances right so that too is a real
danger and it's a it's a danger here and
now I mentioned the Trump Biden Pence
controversies we could include in that
Hillary Clinton in in a sense I mean it
was looked at by the FBI it related more
to an email server uh how do you assess
assess these types of controversies in
terms of how they compare to one another
and kind of the big picture significance
as to how common more generally it is I
mean I I said the other day I wouldn't
be shocked if secretaries of state had a
few documents lying around and it's just
not a high priority to look I I just
don't know
yeah and you know to me I actually do
look at you know whether it's about you
know Hillary Clinton or email or you
know Biden Pence Trump Etc et cetera et
cetera maybe we'll learn even more names
soon enough I also go back to the way in
which story The George W Bush
Administration they used to write their
email using Republican National
Committee email servers right what all
these things have in common is that
these are public officials doing the
people's business and they treat the
record of those actions their decisions
as if it were their private property
where they have no obligation to share
that information with the National
Archives why does that matter because
you know it's our history you know
wouldn't we like to think you know that
as Citizens you know we could file
freedom information act requests right
maybe we'd like to know what the George
W Bush Administration is doing maybe
we'd like to know what secretary Clinton
was doing you know but if they'd gotten
away with it and to be honest to a large
extent they did yeah you know a lot of
those records would never be recoverable
and none of us would ever have the
ability to to see them and so you know
that's why I say like uh as an historian
I take the longer view you know and I'm
sorry to say but you know even if some
of these cases you know the most
egregious of all of course is Donald
Trump even if some of these cases are
worse than others I think we've all of
us got to wake up and see you know that
uh whether it's Democrats doing it or
Republicans do it we we have to
recognize that this is something all of
us should care about when it comes to
the Trump thing like as an example it's
hard to imagine that the things he would
want to have down at his house are email
chains about which Starbucks people are
meeting at but without something more
more tangible maybe it's not totally
clear like what what kinds of things
could they be what does the what are the
sorts of categories of things that he
might have down there that one would
want to have yeah well you know we know
apparently you know that's some of these
documents related to President macron of
France
you know I don't know but I I think uh
it's typically the case that you know
presidents before they have
international meetings they'll get
briefing books right uh we know like
from what Edward Snowden revealed uh
that the NSA you know did try to Target
you know foreign heads of States some of
them allies right that they intercepted
their Communications it's entirely
possible you know that in those records
we have you know examples of how it is
the NSA intercepted Communications maybe
some of them are incriminating and
that's why we're going to talk about
them endlessly because there's something
intrinsically fascinating about
something that's secret and
psychologists have studied this like you
could take random pieces of paper you
stamp them top secret and in controlled
experiments people always think that
those are the pieces of paper that are
more important those are the things they
have to pay attention to you know so yes
it could be a big deal and you know you
know the fact that those documents were
unsecured and could have been stolen I
mean we know that there were foreign
operatives who are active you know
trying to penetrate Mar-A-Lago there was
one guy you know I think he was a
Chinese National who went in with many
uh you know USB sticks right you don't
usually take like eight or ten USB
sticks to the pool
so yes we should be concerned about that
but again I think it's part of a much
bigger story
um the protocol around a lot of these
documents at least as far as members of
the House and Senate have said is
depending on their classification there
would be particular rooms where the
documents are kept where when you go in
you have to leave your phone outside you
know the idea is prevent anybody from
even photographing the documents you're
not allowed to take notes you basically
look at it and I guess the idea is
you're sort of committing to memory
whatever about it is relevant or
interesting or you want to look into is
that a process that makes sense at this
point in time given the the sort of
digital age that we're in yeah well you
know those are the rules that the
executive branch imposes on the
legislative branch and Congress has to
abide by them or they don't get to see
anything right uh but on the other hand
you know it's a well-known fact you know
that when for example you know say
staffers the National Security Council
let's say they go into a meeting you
know to decide what's the US going to do
if China tries to take Taiwan you know
they may be handling lots of classified
records right and they know that they
have to be careful of those records but
when they take notes do you think that
they always classify them even if
they're talking about the same
information it's a well-known fact that
oftentimes those notes go home with them
and sometimes when they leave you know
the National Security Council those
notes end up in their homes right and
staying there one reason for that you
know of course like people want to do
work sometimes people work long hours
they want to be able to work at home but
another reason is a lot of people want
to go on and write their Memoirs right
and and look like when you see all of
the books that come out right both
during but especially after
administration's end when you know who
those people are and how it is that they
go around to Publishers and they get
their big advances is it always because
they are so gifted right at telling a
good story no it's typically because
they say you know at least imply that
they are going to reveal these is
Secrets right these things that they
knew during their time in the Trump
White House so in that way they are
monetizing you know information that's
supposed to belong to all of us so to me
again that is really to me even more so
than say National Security that's the
bigger story here on the issue of the
books you know you will often read
articles that say well a former
Secretary of State wrote a book and the
Pentagon looked at the book to evaluate
whether there was anything being
revealed that you sort of know the drill
what about that process in terms of is
is someone at the Pentagon really so
involved that they would say this name
you mentioned on page 120 you need to
change that and say it's a source you
can't name or like at what level are
they presiding over the books that are
published they will deny it but there
are different rules for different people
right so if you're Mike Pompeo right and
you have amazing things to say you know
about this CIA right and how awesome it
is and how they protect our people all
the time in ways they can't quite reveal
then you're going to get one kind of
reading and you're going to get
different kinds of redactions or maybe
none at all right if you're another kind
of person right like even John Bolton
say and let's say like when you conclude
your time in the Trump White House and
you want to tell all and you want to say
really critical things you know about
the president the former president now
you know then you're going to get a very
different reading they're going to give
you a much harder time it's even harder
you know for people who do not have the
kind of name recognition can't hire the
kind of lawyers you know that somebody
like Bolton can and instead like have to
wait sometime months sometimes years
right to get that reading and God forbid
this is somebody who really wants to
tell you what's really happening you
know whether it's at the NSA or the CIA
those people go through a real ordeal
right and if they make mistakes they get
prosecuted yeah that seems to be an area
where the over classification I mean
people writing their Memoirs is not of
the utmost importance when we think
about the grand scheme of things but it
seems that that's directly affected by
this over classification that you're
talking about where many many government
hours end up going into reviewing the
books and redacting them because of the
very overclassification that is in place
yeah I mean they do uh and they've been
doing it for for decades now I mean
there are some civil liberties lawyers
who are trying to challenge this process
because what they would point out is
like for example after the end of the
Trump Administration wouldn't we like to
know everything we possibly can about
what happened you know in those years
like wouldn't we like to know as much as
we can about January 6. well if it's the
case that currently serving government
officials are the ones to decide what
we're allowed to know then basically
that information is being censored
um and so we're only going to know what
the government allows us to know all in
the name of National Security
hey last thing I I know that your
expertise is in history not Grammar but
I heard you say during this interview
and historian and then you also said a
historian this is actually my audience
writes in about this it is either
correct in your mind
I I've did I really say a historian I
thought well maybe I misheard it
yeah that's fast so I usually say edit
story me too
yeah I don't know if there's a rule yeah
it's not really clear to me it's just my
Quirk well we'll look into it we'll look
into it all right Matthew Connolly
Columbia history Professor we're linking
to his book of the declassification
engine what history reveals about
America's Top Secrets really appreciate
your time and insights today
thank you David
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
failed former president Donald Trump who
again wants to be president starting in
January of 2025 is reportedly planning
to bring back firing squads for the
execution of death penalty sentences and
wants to televise elements of those
executions maybe not the most gruesome
part but at least elements of it this is
all part of Trump's I guess New Look
2024 campaign in which he's talking
about executing drug dealers who he
falsely claims are responsible for 500
deaths each uh a line he is often
repeated at rallies there is a wild wild
Rolling Stone article by asawin subsang
and Patrick rice Trump plans to bring
back firing squads group executions if
he retakes the White House and the
article explains how Donald Trump has
been asking more and more Associates
about this idea Trump is committed to
expanding the use of the death penalty
the article writes and he wants to bring
back some banned methods of execution he
is even One Source says mused about
televising footage of executions
including showing condemned prisoners in
the final moments of their lives this is
very deranged it is extraordinarily
authoritarian and we should all be
genuinely scared about it the article
continues Trump has talked about
bringing back death by firing squad by
hanging and according to two of the
sources possibly even by guillotine he
has also discussed group executions and
he floated these ideas while discussing
planned campaign rhetoric and policy
desires as well as his disdain for
Biden's approach to crime here's another
wild element to this in at least one
instance late last year Trump privately
mused about possibly creating a flashy
government-backed video ad Campaign
which would accompany a federal Revival
of these execution methods in the vision
that Trump has the videos would have
footage from the new executions if not
from the exact moments of death the
source told Rolling Stone the former
president believes this would help put
the fear of God into violent criminals
he wanted to do some of these things
when he was in office but for whatever
reasons he didn't have the chance for
whatever reason Trump wasn't able to
bring back death by guillotine and then
televise the executions we don't know
why he just wasn't able to do it so this
is really really scary and crazy and we
are all right to see this and to cringe
and to say what the hell is this about
this guy is sick but there's another
more practical question I'm wondering
about is this going to get out the vote
is there a desire for from your average
Republican voter to have new and more
not new to revive the more brutal forms
of carrying out execution and death
sentences like the guillotine and firing
squads what about group executions maybe
you know the the the sort of funny
there's very little that's funny about
this very very little it's genuinely
horrifying the one part that is funny is
that there's a little detail in there
that shows Trump's lack of understanding
of how anything works when Trump talks
about group executions we all know it
takes so long to carry out a death
sentence between appeals and backlogs
and all of these different processes
that take place the idea that it would
even be logistically possible
to coordinate multiple Federal
executions on the same day and do it as
a group forget about the morality of it
forget about what it means for the
country forget about all the idea that
it would even be logistically possible
to carry that out just shows Trump's
complete and total lack of understanding
of how anything works and a complete
lack of a connection to reality but he
wants to do it my question is is there
really an appetite for this even from
Republican voters who were willing to
vote Trump do they want this I have a
hard time believing that they do well
ladies and gentlemen uh California
Senator Dianne Feinstein at 89 years old
will not seek re-election in 2024 this
clears the path for a hotly contested
Democratic Primary in that state
involving Adam Schiff Katie Porter and
Barbara Lee as well as others who have
already declared that they are indeed
running we have been wondering for some
time is Dianne Feinstein going to retire
now there are sort of two stories here
first there is the story as CNBC writes
about Feinstein being the oldest sitting
U.S senator and the longest serving
Senator and a growing appetite among
Democrats in various parts of the
country for the next generation of
leaders now what's interesting is the
next Generation after Dianne Feinstein
is still people who are in their 60s so
like two generations later maybe it you
know you understand what I'm saying so
there's the general desire there
the second part and we want to be
respectful when we talk about this is
specifically about Dianne Feinstein and
her cognitive State as for years now
there have been growing concerns about
what is happening with Dianne Feinstein
as she is close to 90 years old pretty
widespread reports of her very quickly
forgetting that she has met people when
she's going through her normal course of
being a senator we have seen a sort of
confused Dianne Feinstein during Senate
hearings during which she will read a
question off of a piece of paper that
she doesn't fully seem to understand and
then she will immediately read the same
question again not realizing that she
already asked that one so it's not
something we laugh at it's it's a sad
situation more than anything but it is
also raised concerns among some
Democrats that because of the power of
incumbency that if she did choose to run
again it could get very messy and
complicated but none of that is going to
happen because 89 year old Dianne
Feinstein says this is going to be it
for her now when you look at the names
of folks that are currently running here
there are a lot of different names some
we recognize for example Katie Porter uh
Adam Schiff
Barbara Lee actually Barbara Lee is not
on this list I thought hold on a second
Barbara Lee
senate race
Lee is planning to launch but has not
yet announced okay there is also a guy
named Barack Obama Mandela who's running
this is not in the Democratic side
remember that in California it is I
believe they call it a jungle primary
where everybody's on the same ballot and
the top two vote Getters make it to the
final election in in November of 2024.
so this is a large list of folks here
because of the political Dynamics in
California very blue State the senate
election in Practical terms is the
primary uh and it becomes clear from the
primary who is ultimately going to be
the senator and Katie Porter versus Adam
Schiff is going to be very interesting
if indeed Barbara Lee announces that she
is running and she's expected to in a
few days this is going to be a primary
with numerous Democratic Heavy Hitters
and I am not taking a position on it at
this time I genuinely don't know what to
expect from such a primary uh Adam
Schiff Barbara Lee and Katie Porter
all three relatively well known shift
probably the best known although Katie
Porter's social media presence is
significant a lot of viral moments she's
very very good in hearings so that's
going to be an interesting primary for
sure it is a good thing it is a good
thing that Dianne Feinstein has said
I've had a great run and she has longest
serving Senator oldest Senator and it
will be very interesting to see the
direction that California voters want to
see their representation go so we will
be certainly covering that race we have
a voicemail number and that number is
219 to David P here is a caller
calling in about whether I will be
fleeing the Northeast to Florida
David it's Alan from Jersey I just heard
you say that you are in fact moving to
Florida you are going to move into the
village with Pat and some of the
Dolphins and ride around the golf carts
and yell out white power I can't believe
that you will be a snowbird because
you're missing the best part of the East
Coast winter is the best season yeah
listen uh I am not moving to Florida as
of this time if I did move to Florida on
a part or full-time basis I would not
live at The Villages I would not shout
white power and I probably would not
swim with the dolphins but no in all
seriousness I know winter spring summer
the changes the snow the folie the
entire I get it I've done it for decades
and I can still get winter if I'm in
Florida January and February right we
still have winter in December and to
some degree March okay so I am thinking
about
for the purpose is of spending time
outdoors and Beach and all these
different things Mental Health
should I become a snowbird many decades
sooner than many people do but no
decisions have been made as of this time
we have a great bonus show on the bonus
show we will talk about remote work
costing Manhattan more than 12 billion
dollars a year we will talk about the
CDC reporting that teen girls are in an
extreme wave of sadness and violence
what is causing it what can and should
be done and we will also talk about
teacher salaries increasingly becoming a
bipartisan cause low pay is being agreed
upon as a major crisis in education all
of those stories and more today not
tomorrow not some other day in the
future today on the bonus show sign up
at joinpakman.com I look forward to
seeing you there